oh you guys are cute
how long have you been together
no idea wow okay not because you're an
[__] I know this I know what this is
this is modern day courtship this is you
guys started [__] and you didn't know
how to label it
pretty much two months three months yeah
that sucked huh I love both of you
trying though that's good that both of
you guys tried but how did you meet you
work in the same industry what's fun
a resident position that's what's up boy
somebody doing it right what kind of
position are you
you're not a position bro this is a
nurse dog why you acting like that's the
same thing that's like saying Jeff Bezos
works in the same industry than Mexican
delivery boys
thank you